[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo l'émission qui revient
sur les temps forts de l'actualité à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat et
avec tam cette semaine nous recevons
alain milon sénateur les républicains
bonjour et ces femmes qui dresse votre
portrait alain millions vous êtes
sénateur l air de vaucluse et vous avez
longtemps occupé la tête de la
commission des affaires sociales vous
venez de lâcher la présidence après le
dernier renouvellement votre famille
politique vous avez choisi pour ce poste
malgré vos positions en faveur de la pma
de la gpa qui détonne à droite
votre profession alain milon médecin
vous êtes d'ailleurs nombreux à exercer
ce métier dans la commission denquête
qu'ovide que vous présidez et qui rendra
ses travaux au mois de décembre
parce que c'est pas difficile d'être
évident de rendre des conclusions en
plein milieu de la crise alors qu'on est
bien en pleine deuxième vague la
commission kobi d'elle qu'elle a été
constitué c'est pour faire un examen des
réactions du gouvernement face à une
crise importante en mars et en avril
oui et pour essayer d'apporter des
réponses ou des solutions aux problèmes
qui se sont posés dans le cadre de la
première vague pas dans le cas de la
deuxième vague de problèmes dans la
deuxième vague
c'est pas le même problème dans la
deuxième vague puisqu'il a l'expérience
de la première
je pense qu'on a tiré quand même des
conséquences positives de cette première
vague quelques conséquences positives
encore oui quand même bien de bien sûr
ne serait-ce qu'au niveau de l'hôpital
non non non on peut pas on peut pas tout
mettre en négatif et dans le temps d'une
escale dans le port du masque
essentiellement dans la distanciation
dans le respect de certaines règles
comme ce lavage des mains je pense que
les conclusions sont positives je pense
que nos concitoyens ont compris la
nécessité du port du masque de distance
et du lavage des mains c'est déjà
considérable
c'est peut-être pas suffisant face à un
virus aussi méchant virulent que celui
là mais on voit bien que et on espère
bien que si on a une épidémie de grippe
qui arrivent en même temps plq au vide
dans quelques jours
les mesures qui sont prises pour lutter
contre qu'ovide permettront d'avoir une
épidémie de grippe nettement moins
virulente que les autres aussi que les
années précédentes
donc c'est un c'est une avance
importante
après pour ce qui est du soin pour ce
qui est de l'hôpital et cetera
les conclusions ont été tirées par le
gouvernement est le diagnostic qui a été
fait est bon après faut du temps
évidemment pour mettre en place des
nouveaux lits de la qualité vous diriez
il ya eu des fautes qui ont été commises
antérieurement à la crise oui pendant la
crise
je ne suis pas sûr que d'autres auraient
mieux fait allez voici à présent les
titres de cette émission la crise
sanitaire fait plonger le déficit de la
sécurité sociale
il devrait atteindre 49 milliards
d'euros en 2020 le quatrième budget
rectificatif voté à l'assemblée
nationale
il vient en aide au petit commerce
durement touché par la crise sanitaire
et enfin le confinement inchangés
pendant les quinze prochains jours
jean castex en appelle au civisme et
demande aux français d'amplifier leurs
efforts
et pour commencer cette émission le
budget de la sécurité sociale à
l'épreuve du sénat
[Musique]
les sénateurs débattent du projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
jusqu'à mardi prochain un texte marqué
par un déficit hors norme 49 milliards
d'euros prévus pour 2020 essentiellement
due à l'effort qu'ovide résumé des
débats avec samia de chair l'épidémie de
covile fait replonger les comptes de la
sécurité sociale dans le rouge écarlate
le fameux trou de la sécu atteindra 40 9
milliards d'euros en 2020 contre moins
de 2 milliards l'an passé
en cause l'explosion des dépenses de
santé et la baisse des recettes liées
aux cotisations sociales
à situation exceptionnelle budget
exceptionnel explique le ministre de la
santé
bien sûr j'entends les craintes
légitimes qui évoque des pentes
vertigineuses
mais c'est la situation verte ici c'est
la situation sanitaire qui est avant
tout verte est vertigineuse l' équilibre
des comptes est une chose et je suis
très attaché mais répondre à la détresse
et construire la protection sociale de
demain ça n'est pas accessoire c'est
indispensable
la protection sociale de demain c'est
bien ce qui inquiète la majorité
sénatoriale
elle accuse le gouvernement d'augmenter
les dépenses sans savoir comment les
financer
pour trouver de nouvelles ressources les
sénateurs proposent plusieurs pistes par
exemple du côté des complémentaires
santé le sénat a modifié le texte pour
doubler leur contribution au budget de
la sécurité sociale
une mesure qui devrait rapporter 1
milliard d'euros
il ya moins de charges donc on va
appeler les mutuelles comme les
assureurs ne sont pas tenus à augmenter
les cotisations puisque effectivement
hibon rien perdre
on va simplement prendre effectivement
un peu plus sur leurs excédents le sénat
reproche aussi au gouvernement de ne pas
compenser certaines exonérations de
cotisations sociales sur les heures
supplémentaires par exemple
ces exonérations décidé avant la crise
c'est autant de recettes en moins pour
la sécurité sociale
le texte modifié par le sénat prévoit
donc leur compensation par l'état en
refusant de compenser intégralement les
exonérations de cotisations sociales
l'état agit comme si finalement la
sécurité sociale était devenu son
porte-monnaie qu'ils pouvaient agir
bon lui semble la compensation des
exonérations sociales par l'état
pourrait rapporter 4 milliards d'euros
aux caisses de la sécurité sociale
pas de quoi absorber pour autant déficit
qui frôle désormais les 50 milliards
d'euros
et oui le déficit pour 2020 a été revu
pour atteindre désormais 49 milliards
d'euros à la mi longs est ce que vous
pensez qu'ils risquent même d'être
supérieur en raison de la deuxième vague
de cette crise sanitaire le déficit tel
qu'il est construit est consécutif à la
crise deuxième vague du covin c'est
évident et les cantiques au tiff aussi
aux accords salariaux pour pour ma part
le ségur accords salariaux qui sont
largement justifiée puisqu'il quand même
pendant plusieurs années vous les saluer
oui oui tout à fait parce qu'il pendant
plusieurs années les salaires des
hospitaliers quel que soit leur métier
ont été bloqués par des honda hm qui
était largement insuffisant alors si on
retire le coc vide si on retire le ségur
en fait on n'y a rien de nouveau dans le
plfss qui permettent d'envisager une
amélioration de la santé nos dos de nos
concitoyens dans l'année à venir dans
les années à venir
donc moi cela m'a sécurité sociale c'est
pas un pansement parce que c'est loin
d'être un pansement 4 milliards c'est
plus important mais c'est insuffisant
dans le dans les prévisions pour
l'avenir d'haïti creed et social c'est
suffisant pour agir dans l'immédiateté
mais c'est totalement insuffisant pour
prévoir l'avenir de sécurité sociale et
en particulier pour faire en sorte qu'il
y ait une nouvelle organisation de la
santé sur le territoire national c'est
un peu ce que j'ai dit dans le cadre de
la discussion générale je trouve que on
aurait dû profiter du coc vide
profitez de cette crise énorme pour se
rendre compte qu'il ya des choses qui ne
marchent pas au niveau de l'organisation
des ars par rapport aux régions au
niveau d'organisation des services par
rapport au paul dans les hôpitaux au
niveau de la direction mais ça ça doit
être dans un projet de maintenance et la
sécurité sociale dans une loi de santé
une nouvelle loi santé l'excusé de dire
que cela devrait être dans une nouvelle
loi de santé
et ce pour ne pas y aura bascule pour ne
pas refaire une santé il y aura pas trop
le temps pour refaire une nouvelle loi
de santé d'ici les élections
présidentielles là il y avait l'occasion
rêvée de pouvoir améliorer les choses et
en plus de pouvoir faire en sorte que
issus de l'expérience qui a été faite
crisique au vide en particulier au
niveau de l'hôpital
l'organisation qui a été mise en place
par les médecins en accord avec
l'administration
si on avait simplement fait ça à côté
d'eux des revalorisations salariales
c'est un programme des mesures du ségur
de la santé si la revalorisation
salariale
oui c'est pas est-ce que ça permet
d'avoir un hôpital digne de ce nom
au lendemain de la crise non digne de ce
nom je sais pas ce que ça veut dire
digne de ce nom
mais l'hôpital actuellement pendant la
crise est obligé d'ailleurs comme
l'équipe privée de renoncer à certains
soins pour permettre de faire front à la
crise qu vide or ce renoncement va
entraîner évidemment d'étape de chance
pour la plupart des patients et donc il
est nécessaire que lorsque l'on aura une
nouvelle crise et il aurait fallu
prévoir de suite on soit capable de
faire front à la crise sans être obligé
d'arrêter certains soins nécessaires par
ailleurs et c'est là le problème pour
l'instant pas régionale 1 million il ya
deux ans vous vouliez déjà taxer les
complémentaires santé avec et bien ce
plfss vous avez eu enfin gain de cause
cette fois ci donc c'est pour financer
la qu'ovide avant vous vous lire
valorisé avec les retraites est ce que
vous ne craignez pas on a entendu des
arguments dans l'hémicycle que les
mutuelles que les autres complémentaires
augmentent leurs tarifs et qu'au final
les assurés soit lésé suis je crains je
crains beaucoup c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
que nous avions présenté des amendements
pour bien dire que le prélèvement qui a
été fait était consécutif à la crise qu
vide et à l'absence de dépenses d'un par
des organismes complémentaires
d'assurance maladie et donc
l'amendement que nous avons présentés
c'était de dire le prélèvement est fait
pour ça et les prochaines les mutuelles
les organismes complémentaires n'ont pas
le droit d'augmenter leurs tarifs
majorité n'ont pas été voter les
français économiser 1,2 milliard 6 vous
rêvez qu'un milliard donc elles ont un
milliard six dans la poche si on
pourrait dire bas dans le meilleur des
cas
oui elle décide de d'impact et cela
s'inverse et c'est pour ça que j'avais
proposé à la dg cancon créer une
assurance maladie universelle que
l'ensemble des cotisations y compris les
cotisations mutuelles soient versés à
une caisse qui gère l'ensemble est que
chaque année à la fin de l'année l'année
passée s'il y a des bénéfices ces
bénéfices sont redistribués aux
cotisants et s'il ya des pertes
on augmente les cotisations mais on ne
fait pas une augmentation systématique
alors qu'on sait très bien par ailleurs
il suffit de le dire les rapports de la
cour des comptes pour se rendre compte
que l'ensemble des organismes
complémentaires d'assurance maladie font
des frais de gestion considérable et des
frais de publicité important est par
ailleurs de bénéficier respectable toute
dernière question très rapidement dans
ce budget il ya aussi le doublement du
congé paternité qui passe de 14 à 28
jours dont sept jours obligatoires il ya
beaucoup de vos collègues au groupe
heller qui sont opposés notamment le
président de votre groupe bruno
retailleau
vous êtes d'accord avec lui non non non
je sais tu pas une mesure que j'aurais
prise
si j'avais eu à faire quelque chose dans
le cadre de ce plfss parce que je ne
pense pas que ce soit une mesure qui
assure l'avenir de la sécurité sociale
telle qu'on la connaît et elle concon à
vous devrez toujours par ailleurs ça
finalement
c'est une mesure respectable n'y a pas
de problème et je doive autres et il
aurait fallu aller plus loin dans les
jours obligatoires y a que sept jours
obligatoires sur un 28 jours de congé
paternité
non je pense aussi que dans période de
crise que telle qu'elle est actuellement
il faut aussi regarder ce qui se passe
au niveau entreprise et est à la fois
respecter le fait que le congé paternité
est important pour l'enfant et pour la
famille et à la fois ne pas le rendre
trop long pour respecte également les
équilibres financiers des entreprises
qui sont en difficulté
justement on va en parler c'est un autre
texte qui illustre les dégâts de la
crise sanitaire le collectif budgétaire
saison 4 les députés l'ont examinée à
cette semaine
[Musique]
le quatrième budget rectificatif a été
adopté par l'assemblée nationale il
prévoit 20 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires pour faire face aux
dépenses de la deuxième vague de
l'épidémie de vide
l'accent est mis sur les aides aux
petits commerces contraints à la
fermeture l amende à gaza ce plfr 4 est
là pour soutenir les commerces français
il est là pour les aider à passer ce
moment particulièrement difficile qui je
le sais partout en france suscitent
parfois de l'incompréhension parfois de
la colère est partout une immense
détresse
la mesure principale l'élargissement du
fonds de solidarité aux entreprises de
moins de 50 salariés jusqu'à 10000 euros
pour le mois de novembre pour compenser
la perte du chiffre d'affaires ce qui
fait que le montant total que nous avons
prévu pour le fonds solidarité en
novembre 6 milliards d'euros est
l'équivalent de tout ce qui a été
dépensé pour le fonds de solidarité
depuis sa création au mois de mars
dernier le gouvernement maintient ou
mettent en place d'autres dispositifs
exonérations de charges chômage partiel
aide à la digitalisation décalage des
remboursements des prêts garantis par
l'état
le ministre de l'économie encourage par
ailleurs les bailleurs à renoncer à leur
loyer du mois de novembre
en échange d'un crédit d'impôt pour ce
quatrième exercice de budget
rectificatif on retrouve les mêmes
préoccupations chez les oppositions
l'équilibré budgétaire à droite la
taxation des plus riches à gauche je
profite de cette date du 50e
anniversaire de la mort du général de
gaulle pour rappeler ces sages paroles
celle qu'il prononçait en 1963 et de
demander des sous des sous des sous ou
bien des crédits des crédits toujours
des crédits mais les souhaits les
crédits ne saurait être alloué que si
nous les possédons les assurances les
gaffes à les grandes fortunes
le capital eux ne seront pas mis à
contribution encore une fois ce sont
donc les mêmes qui payent les mêmes qui
souffrent et les mêmes qui profitent
la droite a voté pour la gauche contre
et tous ont déploré les conditions
d'examen de ce budget rectificatif
il a fallu cg jusqu'à 5 heures du matin
mercredi alain milon l'accent est mis
sur les petits commerces qui sont cons
la fermeture est ce que vous voyez là
les moyens de résister à la crise je ne
suis pas persuadé mais alors pas du tout
que la fermeture des des petits
commerces avec l'ouverture à côté des
hypers soit une solution pourrait pour
endiguer l'épidémie
je pense qu'au contraire quand on
autorise la masse de nos concitoyens à
se déplacer en masse vers des hypers
commerçants favorise l'évolution
d'épidémie et se relever ces petits
commerces avec le fonds de garantie avec
le chômage partiel avec les praticiens
jeu dont beaucoup visent qu'à dix mille
euros pour les petits commerçants c'est
qu'elle ne se relèveront pas tout une
évidence mais il aurait fallu autorisé
le petit commerce a continué quitte à
faire en sorte qu' il y ait qu un client
à la fois dans dans dans la surface de
vente
mais je pense que les petits commerces
ne sont pas des vecteurs du virus par
contre les restaurants une étude
américaine a montré d'ailleurs les
restaurants sont vendus grands vecteurs
de virus et les bas sont des grands
vecteurs du virus mais pour le reste non
et les vrais des vrais vecteurs du virus
même avec les mesures qui sont mises en
place de distanciation de masques etc
c'est lorsqu'il y a des masses de
populations qui sont entre deux de ses
concitoyens qui se trouve entre collés
les uns aux autres c'est le vrai pour
les transports en commun et c'est vrai
pour les grandes surfaces
donc les propositions faites sont des
populations intéressante bien sûr mais
qui sont nécessaires parce que les
décisions qui ont été prises me semble
pas être la bonne il ya 10 millions de
pauvres nous dit le secours catholique
il y aura 10 millions de pauvres à la
fin de l'année 2020 est-ce qu'il y en a
assez pour les plus modestes pour les
plus vulnérables dans ce budget non non
non c'est évident mais est ce que c'est
la solution de de toujours donner aux
plus modestes
est-ce que la solution n'est pas
d'essayer de relancer une activité
économique suffisante pour que les plus
modestes puissent avoir une évidence en
fait c'est pas évident ce n'est pas à la
hauteur mais ce n'est pas suffisant il
faudrait une taxe exceptionnelle
peut-être pourquoi pas sur les plus
riches pourquoi pas oui sur amazon aussi
pour aider les petits commerces alors
sur les gaffes un oui très volontiers
mais même là plusieurs s'il fallait je
pense que là aussi par contre non
seulement il faudrait que nous puissions
agir financièrement sur ces grandes
entreprises
il faudrait que dans le même temps nos
concitoyens aient le sentiment que faire
travailler amazon s'est tué leur
commerce local situé le grand commerce
français et donc elle pas déjà le cas
parce que finalement les français
utilisent assez peu amazon par rapport à
un certain nombre de nos voisins à 20%
même s'ils utilisent moins que les
autres ils l'utilisent beaucoup trop par
rapport à notre goût version locale donc
il faudrait qu'il ya une prise de
conscience à ce niveau là la part de nos
concitoyens à la mêlée on a entendu à
eric woerth qui dit des sous des sous
des sous en reprenant pascal réglé
jettera la phrase voilà alors qu'elle
imite faut-il au quoi qu'il en coûte on
est quand même en train de dépenser un
argent que nous n'avons vraiment pas eu
la bibitte au quoi qu'il en coûte c'est
la limite de la souffrance de nos
concitoyens il faudrait faire en sorte
que les commerçants les petits
commerçants que les pauvres ceux qui
sont diagnostiqués comme pauvres par le
secours catholique soit le aider au
maximum pour que cette crise se passe au
mieux pour eux donc la limite elle
n'existait qu'à ce niveau là pas
vraiment elle n'y a pas vraiment de
limite pour moi dans la mesure où on
doit évidemment aider nos concitoyens le
mieux possible et enfin eric c'est le
problème de la dette quand même la bonne
dette finalement parce que y'a la
relance il ya de l'investissement de la
bonne dette mais c'est de la dette
humaine mais d'investir aussi d'investir
ça permet de faire en sorte que nous
concitoyens ne soient pas complètement
déprimé ça permet de lutter contre une
déprime nationale non c'est pas une
dette bonne parce que la dette n'est
jamais bonne
mais humainement parlant elle est
acceptable et elle est souhaitable vous
le vôtre et ses budgets
oui oui vous l'âme andré peut-être
probable dans quel sens vous avez des
idées déjà on entend pas encore il faut
que je vois pas ce que nous sénat on l'a
pas encore on la semaine prochaine ne
peut les faire donc il faut qu'on
regarde ça pour l'instant moi je suis
complètement plongé sans le peler les
fessées et je vais vous dire que c'est
largement suffisant pour pur bonheur
pour l'instant à léo termine avec le
plus de la semaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les jean castex a fait un point d'étape
cette semaine sur leur confinement le
premier ministre ne changent rien aux
règles pendant les quinze prochains
jours
il espère un allègement pour noël il
parle aussi d'un éventuel des serments
pour les commerces au 1er décembre
on écoute des premières mesures
d'allégement pourrait intervenir à
compter du 1er décembre mais elle serait
strictement limitée au commerce que nous
avons dû fermer à partir du confinement
et leur réouverture ne pourrait
s'envisager que sur la base d'un
protocole renforcé
l'objectif est de pouvoir permettre un
nouvel allègement au moment des vacances
de noël afin que les français puissent
passer des fêtes de fin d'année en
famille mais celles ci ne pourront pas
se tenir de la même manière que
d'habitude on pourra bien sûr se
retrouver avec les siens mais il ne
serait pas raisonnable d'espérer pouvoir
organiser de grandes fêtes à plusieurs
dizaines de personnes notamment pour le
réveillon du 31 décembre
alain milon selon le premier ministre ce
sont ses mots il serait irresponsable
d'alléger le confinement est ce que
c'est pas aussi une nouvelle façon de
tacler les oppositions qui réclame on
vous a entendu tout à l'heure toujours
la réouverture des petits commerces
c'est la réponse du premier ministre à
la crise je vous dis prenez pas pour
vous et pour bien tous ceux qui ont
voulu la réouverture des petits
commerces non rapidement non je pense
moi que l'erreur c'était de fermer les
petits commerces
c'est une erreur au niveau de
l'évolution de l'épidémie
il aurait mieux valu ouvrir laissées
ouvertes vous vers les petits commerces
avoir peut-être des mesures plus plus
importante au moment de l'accueil de nos
concitoyens dans ces petits commerces
que de laisser les grands commerces
convoque la le gouvernement ouvert la
voie une ouverture dans les 15 prochains
jours peut-être début décembre
vous demandez-vous cette réouverture
bien sûr bien sûr et le bien sûr que je
demande mais encore une fois le
gouvernement ne peut pas ça je le
comprends et rigueur
c'est psychologiquement difficile à
admettre qu'il a eu tort
donc plutôt que de dire j'ai eu tort on
va rouvrir et puis samedi battant
compréhensible on a souvent quand même
dénoncé une une stratégie un peu
erratique du gouvernement est ce que là
vous saluer quand même le statu quo pour
ne pas changer les règles tout le temps
finalement oui bien sûr on est bien
obligé mais quand on a pris une décision
il faut la maintenir
qu'elles soient bonnes ou moins bonnes
bon c'est c'est un principe
gouvernementale évident mais il aurait
été mieux
comme pour les stocks de masques de dire
la vérité aux françaises et aux français
de dire si vous allez en masse dans un
hypermarché vous et vous attraperez
qu'ovide si vous allez séparés avec des
mesures particulièrement ferme un par un
et c'est dans les petits commerces ne
l'attrapé pas et là le problème était
réglé le reconnaître c'est pas évident
que je reconnais volontiers que c'est
difficile pour un mix de dire j'ai eu
tort oui mais bon après tout temps en
temps ça fait pas de mal non plus de se
rendre compte que nous ne sommes que des
humains est donc tout à fait capable de
se tromper de temps en temps à la maison
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la mise en
place des conseils de défense sanitaire
ou se sont prises et bien les décisions
qui ont été annoncés jeudi
est ce que vous vous joignez à ce on
l'entend qui commencent à critiquer dans
le manque de transparence de ce conseil
dont on ne connaît pas très bien le
statut non non non non on peut toujours
évidemment critiquer toutes les
décisions qui sont prises
un moment ou un autre les politiques ont
besoin d'être entouré de scientifiques
des deux gens qui ont des compétences
particulières et après ce conseil ce
conseil doit donner des orientations
politiques cette matière qui décide du
conseil de défense c'est à dire la serbe
le conseil dominé conseil des ministres
c'est à dire qui s'est réuni jeudi matin
non mais alors là par contre le conseil
de défense doit être un conseil
simplement de conseil c'est le conseil
des ministres c'est le politique qui
doivent décider doit parler de
sanitaires le conseil de défense
oui oui oui oui c'est normal qu'il soit
traité de défense y as que vous saluer
la position de gérard larcher une
position de sagesse on pourrait dire
d'accepter finalement un report des
élections départementales et régionales
au mois de juin
oui gérard larcher est un grand sage
était un grand c'est un grand homme
politique mais pour vous aussi on arrête
la nouveauté au mois de mars
il ya un risque mars c'est la fin de
l'hiver mars
on n'est pas sûr que le coc vie ne soit
complètement disparu mars on n'est pas
sûr que la grippe soit pas encore là
donc prendre une décision de ce type là
c'est ça ne s'est pas exactement une
mauvaise décision
le reporter en juin ça veut dire le
reporter à la fin du printemps au début
de l'été il ya moins de risque de
d'épidémie importante et donc non c'est
votre date limite quand même juin où on
peut aller au delà si toutefois le virus
yann le virus est toujours là on peut
doubler
on peut aller au delà septembre aller au
delà c'est à dire quand quand on aura
plus de virus quand les riches les même
si c'est après la présidentielle par
exemple pourquoi pas à ces montants
seraient pas plus de problèmes moins
savoureuse mais voit quand même des
candidats les républicains aux
régionales qui pourraient éventuellement
être candidat à la présidentielle
oui alors est ce que est ce que le fait
de encore une fois qu'on me posait une
question c'est au niveau me dit joint
aux caisses il ya plus de coville ou ci
a pas de risque majeur pour la santé la
sécurité sanitaire septembre s'il n'y a
pas de risque majeur pour la sécurité
sanitaire
mais s'il ya un risque majeur pour la
sécurité sanitaire est ce que le destin
politique des hommes politiques qui
veulent se présenter à la population
pour avoir un destin national est plus
important que la sécurité sociale et
travailler on va à l'école on va au
collège mais on ne peut pas voter ça
c'est compréhensible pour les français
parce que quand on va à l'école dont
d'abord vous savez très bien
ministre a raison là dessus les enfants
ne sont pas les plus exposés aux co vide
et de son pareil pour la plupart d'entre
eux des vecteurs du coc vide pour ça il
n'y a pas de problème là dessus c'est
plus contesté par personne donc là ça va
après pour aller travailler
la plupart du temps maintenant la
distanciation respecter les masses sont
respectés et les mélange des populations
ne se font pas au niveau des mélanges et
génération là dans un vote
il ya la distanciation qui risque de ne
pas être respecté les mélange des
générations qui risque d'être dangereux
si le virus est toujours là si le virus
est pas là évidemment faut voter le plus
rapidement possible mais s'il veut aussi
dit voilà il faut assurer la sécurité
des générations déjà merci beaucoup
alain milon d'avoir répondu à nos
questions merci
brigitte merci à vous de nous avoir
suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
parlement hebdo notre invité roland
lescure le président de la commission
des affaires économiques à l'assemblée
nationale
très bonne journée à tous
[Musique]